actors are used to getting all dolled up
while on set or when attending
prestigious events and photo shoot but
other than that they're used to going
bare face just like the rest of us
seeing your favorite actors without
makeup on can be quite a shock but not
necessarily in a bad way do you know
what actors like dove Cameron debby ryan
and Joe Joe Siva look like without
makeup keep watching to find out skinny
isn't magic there's no denying that dove
Cameron is one of the most beautiful and
successful Disney stars of all time
doves started acting when she was just
15 years old and back then she was known
for her natural beauty but as the star
got older she got more and more into
makeup and is now often pictured looking
flawless still Duff isn't afraid to go
natural every now and then the 24 year
old star often post pictures of herself
with no makeup on and to say that she's
naturally pretty would be an
understatement whether she's sporting
the face full of makeup or going all
natural dove has a unique and youthful
look about her I like to sleep with all
this natural light coming in just like
does Chloe grace Moretz is an actor who
looks good with or without makeup she's
not afraid to step outside while
sporting a barefaced her comfiest pair
of leggings and an oversized sweatshirt
the 23 year old star has a very youthful
glow she can go from the girl next door
to the girl on the cover of Glamour
magazine and just a few brush strokes
but Chloe isn't one to hide behind
makeup in fact she has almost turned
down projects because she found out that
her skin would be retouched Chloe took
on the hashtag of bare skin projects in
the summer of 2018 she even did a bear
skin photo shoot to promote
self-acceptance I wanted to be like her
and I confused that with being with her
as a dancer Chloe Lucchese AK knows how
important it is to look your best on
stage that as a reality TV star she also
knows how important it is to be yourself
Chloe isn't someone who enjoys being
photographed without makeup on she tends
to look her best everywhere she goes the
18 year old got her start on TLC's Dance
Moms where she was often captured
without makeup Chloe looks much older
when she's wearing a full face of
cosmetics but seeing her in her natural
state is a reminder of just how young
she really is Chloe loves makeup and
enjoys teaching her followers all about
her skincare routine so she's not
opposed to skipping the makeup process
before shooting the video so that's why
I use brown shadows most of the time
Emma Watson grew up on the set of Harry
Potter where she was made to wear lots
of makeup according to Emma who spoke to
Vogue she suffered from acne while
shooting the fourth Harry Potter film
and had to douse herself in the
foundation this experience led Emma to
realize how important it is to go bear
face as it lets the skin breathe despite
being a model and actor emma enjoys
going barefaced whenever she can and
we're not too surprised to see that emma
looks just as beautiful with or without
makeup she's all about natural beauty
and skin care but that isn't to say that
she won't wear a full face of makeup
when attending prestigious events I
decided that I was a feminist and this
seemed uncomplicated to me
Sarah Jeffery isn't someone who steps
out of the house without any makeup on
in fact it's rare to come across a
picture of her without at least mascara
or lipstick on Sarah looks a lot younger
without makeup which isn't always the
look she's trying to convey the 23 year
old actor is well known for portraying
Princess Audrey in The Descendants
franchise she's also famous for playing
Maggie Dara on the TV series charmed
although Sarah doesn't need to wear
makeup to look like a model
she tends to leave her home looking her
very best Sarah is a vegan - who is
vocal about using cruelty-free products
according to WWD Sarah wears a lot of
makeup which is why she likes her
skincare to be natural
Audrey princess Audrey Sleeping Beauty's
daughter Meg Donnelly's stole our hearts
when she portrayed Addison in the
zombies franchise max age can be hard to
pinpoint Sienna she can go from looking
like a high school student to a blonde
bombshell in a matter of seconds meg has
a very unique look that can be
downplayed or enhanced by using makeup
alone she's got big blue eyes had popped
like crazy when contouring them with
black eyeliner the 19 year old star as a
model through and through
she isn't often showcased without makeup
on however you can see what she
naturally looks like in this audition
tape in this video meg is auditioning
for the role of Addison and she's
sporting a neutral look I'm so excited
to see well to say that Vanessa Hudgins
is a natural beauty would be an
understatement but there is a huge
difference between Vanessa with makeup
and Vanessa without makeup Vanessa
doesn't typically go out without any
makeup on were used to seeing her with
her classic Cateye look and bright red
lipstick but when you take those away
from her Vanessa goes from looking like
a famous actor to an everyday woman the
High School Musical star posted a
barefaced picture of herself on
instagram and it's here that we see that
her lashline and eyebrows are a lot
softer than we were led to believe still
fans were startled to see how radiant
Vanessa's skin was and how cute and
naturally pretty she was underneath all
that makeup miss Deneuve oh did you say
you are a baker yeah
Debbie Ryan is the gorgeous actor who
portrays the beauty queen Patty Bledel
on Netflix is insatiable obviously she
looks great with or without makeup but
the celeb redoes use makeup to hide
something she doesn't like about herself
Debby revealed that she has freckles in
real life and uses makeup to hide them
away which according to the star is
exhausting
the 26 year old actor isn't afraid to go
without any makeup on but fans have
stated that she can look unrecognizable
without the slightest smidge of eyeliner
would you recognize Debbie if she was
walking down the street sporting a bear
face tell us in the comments I might be
skinny on the outside but on the inside
I am still fatty patty Disney star
Payton list has grown up before our eyes
we've seen her without makeup on
multiple occasions especially when she
was younger but now that the star is in
her early 20s she tends to leave the
house looking her best
Payton's thick eyebrows are one of her
most recognizable traits so it might
come as a surprise to see the star
without any makeup on seeing as her
eyebrows are noticeably thinner she's
also known for her wide eyes which also
appear a lot smaller without makeup
either way Payton is a natural beauty
who would consider her everyday look to
border on natural I'm super fashion
woman faster than an airport mani-pedi
more powerful than a platinum Charge
Card just like her former Dance Moms
co-star Chloe Lucchese ACK Maddie
Ziegler isn't afraid to take off her
makeup and show the world what she
really looks like without makeup Maddie
looks like the young 17 year old that
she is however the star completely
transforms when donning on a full face
of cosmetics Maddie can go from looking
like a schoolgirl to a full-blown model
with just a few brush strokes the
transformation is mind-blowing but
doesn't take away from the fact that she
looks amazing without makeup in November
of 2019
Maddie posted a picture of herself on a
boat without any makeup on and Sheila
just like the Maddie we came to love on
Dance Moms keep watching to find out
which one of Maddie's former co-stars
looks completely different without
makeup
to wrap up my ALDC journey with the win
makeup enhances our features and brings
out the most beautiful versions of
ourselves but there's nothing like
wearing your real face out in public and
still coming off as a total bombshell
this is the case for actor and model
scindia Coleman whose natural beauty
always manages to shine through however
there's no denying that there's a huge
difference between the glammed up
zendaya
and her own natural counterparts this
picture of Scindia eating pizza isn't
the most flattering but it does remind
us that celebrities are normal people
just like the rest of us
zendaya is an adorable star who can go
from cute to stunning with the teeniest
bit of makeup I don't really care about
the situation because it just doesn't
seem safe
Maddie Ziggler's former co-star Jojo
Siva isn't known for letting her natural
self shine she has a brand to protect
after all Jojo is typically seen with a
high ponytail a large bow and
multicolored makeup it's hard to believe
that Jojo is only 16 years old sure she
might look and act young but her face is
always made up to the nines so what does
the former Dance Moms star look like in
real life well we caught a look at the
fresh-faced Jojo in the movie flirt and
she was unrecognizable if you take away
JoJo's makeup accessories and flashy
clothes
she's just an average sixteen year old
girl
just like Jojo Millie Bobbie Brown is a
16 year old superstar who is loved by
many she got her big break when she was
cast as 11 on the Netflix series
stranger things and has been in the
limelight
ever since while on the show Milly comes
off as a young preteen who doesn't care
about fashion or makeup but this isn't
the case in real life Milly loves to
dress up and wear cosmetics making her
look much older than she is it's easy to
forget that Milly is just a teenager but
there's nothing like seeing a picture of
her without any makeup on to remind us
of her age Milly is adorable whether she
wears makeup or not I like the new look
by the way it's cool thanks
Sophia Carson is so gorgeous it's hard
to imagine her any other way
luckily we don't have to because she's
one of those lucky ladies who looks
fantastic with or without makeup how
does she do it
well she spends a lot of time taking
care of her skin she wears sunblock
every single day and exfoliates and
moisturizes to keep her healthy glow
alive although we're used to seeing
Sophia all dolled up especially on her
Instagram page she told people that she
goes makeup free whenever she isn't
working but Sophia isn't the only
naturally beautiful Descendants star you
know what we should try an icebreaker
Chyna and MacLean isn't someone who
wears tons of makeup before leaving the
house she loves her natural side and
embraces it unlike Sarah Jeffery dove
Cameron and Sophia Carson Chyna's
Instagram page is full of natural
pictures of herself when China does wear
makeup she opts for a natural look and
it does wonders for her the 21 year old
actor is gorgeous and humble a little
make-up goes a long way for the star who
completely transforms whenever she dolls
herself up and that's a wrap on what
your favorite actors look like without
makeup
would you recognize them in public if
they were kicking it all naturelle tell
us in the comments and be sure to tell
us who you think looks the best without
any makeup on every single person
standing here it's just one bad
breakaway becoming somebody they never
meant to be thanks for watching the
things like and subscribe for more we'll
see you next time
[Music]